MAY BE A FEW MONTHS BEHIND BARS.
WE WENT TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE DEMOCRATS
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ CONTINUING FAR
LEFT CRUSADE AGAINST ANYTHING,
EVERYTHING PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
ONE ITSY-BITSY PROBLEM.
REALITY KEEPS GETTING IN THE
WAY.
SHE WAS RECENTLY ASKED ABOUT TOP
THREE REASONS TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
A LITTLE TROUBLE ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
KIND OF BECOMING COMMON.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU COULD REACH IN A BAG AND
PULL SO MANY THINGS OUT THAT ARE
IMPEACHABLE OF THIS PRESIDENT.
I SUPPORT IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT.
>> TWO AND THREE?
TWO AND THREE.
I THINK TWO WOULD BE TAX FRAUD.
AND NUMBER THREE WOULD
AND NUMBER THREE -OULD
AND NUMBER THREE --ULD
MAN, THERE IS JUST SO MUCH.
THE CONSENSUS, YOU KNOW, I CAN'T
EVEN -- THE TAX BILL, IT'S LIKE,
THERE IS SO MUCH.
>> Sean: THERE ARE JUST SO
MANY THINGS THAT I CAN'T FIND
ONE OF THEM.
I'M WORKING ON IT.
ALSO WRAPPING UP RADICALISM OF
TAKING AIM AT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ALLIES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> I THINK WHAT WE ARE REALLY
SAYING IS THE AUTHORITARIANISM
ACROSS THE WORLD.
I THINK THAT BENJAMIN NETANYAHU.
>> WOULD YOU BE IN FAVOR OF
REDUCING MILITARY ECONOMIC AID
TO ISRAEL?
I THINK IT'S ON THE TABLE,
CERTAINLY ON THE TABLE.
IT IS SOMETHING TO CERTAINLY BE
DISCUSSED.
>> Sean: WHILE THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY JUST BEGINNING,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ MAKING
ONE THING CLEAR.
SHE DOESN'T WANT JOE BIDEN TO BE
THE NOMINEE.
OH, BOY, I GUESS SHE DECIDES,
NOT NANCY PELOSI.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IDEA THAT WE CAN GO BACK
TO THE GOOD OLD DAYS WITH OBAMA,
WITH OBAMA AS PRESIDENT MY THINK
THERE IS AN EMOTIONAL ELEMENT TO
THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK.
I WANT TO GO FORWARD.
>> Sean: THE REACTION OF
SKYBRIDGE CAPITAL, RACHEL WITH
US, GOOD TO SEE YOU, MAN?
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Sean: SO MANY THINGS.
>> Anthony: WHERE DO YOU WANT
TO START?
AOC OUT OF NEW YORK ASAP.
SECONDARILY, NANCY PELOSI WHOSE
DAUGHTER SAID SHE COULD CUT
SOMEBODY'S THROAT WITHOUT THEM
FEELING IT WILL TAKE HER OUT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
CHANCE --
>> Sean: NOT ONLY EXTREMISM
PARTY BUT SCARED TO DEATH OF THE
FIVE.
>> Anthony: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> Sean:
RE Sean:
REMAean:
REMARKn:
REMARKABLY SUCCESSFUL SURVIVOR
IN WASHINGTON AND OLD SCHOOL.
THIS SORT OF BEHAVIOR COME I
DON'T THINK WILL LAST VERY LONG.
THAT IS MY HONEST OPINION.
THEY WILL FIND SOMEBODY TO
CHALLENGE HER IN THAT DISTRICT.
SHE WILL NOT COME BACK BUT
SOMEBODY MORE MODERATE WILL TAKE
HER OUT.
SHE DESTROYED HERSELF WITH THE
AMAZON THING.
SHE IS COLORFUL.
SHE'S GOT INTERESTING WAYS TO
ATTRACT ATTENTION TO HERSELF,
BUT I THINK NEW YORK IS GETTING
TIRED OF HER QUICKLY.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
PELOSI'S INTERVIEW AND FLUFF
BALL INTERVIEW ON "60 MINUTES"?
IT WAS ONLY FIVE BUT COMING TO
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR, AND O
CONSEIL CORTEZ, NANCY PELOSI
DOES NOT SEEM TO SHOW AN ABILITY
TO STAND UP TO THEM.
>> NANCY PELOSI IS NOT WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE HEART
OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY ILHAN OMAR
AND ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ AND
BY THE WAY BERNIE SANDERS IS THE
NUMBER ONE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE RIGHT NOW.
HE'S GOT ALL THE ENERGY.
THE PARTY, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AS A SOCIALIST PARTY.
WHEN ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
SAYS SHE DOESN'T WANT TO GO
BACKWARDS, SHE DOESN'T WANT OLD
MAN JOE BIDEN BUT WE WANT TO
EMBRACE SOCIALISM WHOLLY,
COMPLETELY.
AN ECONOMICALLY IGNORANT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND EVEN THOUGH SHE HAS
A -- SOCIALISM IS GOING
BACKWARDS.
SO THOSE IDEAS HAVE NEVER
WORKED.
AND IT IS DANGEROUS FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THE KIND OF POPULARITY AND
MAINSTREAMING THAT ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND BERNIE SANDERS
HAVE RIGHT NOW WHETHER NANCY
WANTS TO ADMIT IT OR NOT.
>> Sean: ANTHONY, BESIDES
CRAZY CREEPY UNCLE JOE BIDEN --
JOE BIDEN, THE HARDEST THING HE
HAS TO DEAL WITH, HE WILL BRING
BACK THE SAME POLICIES ON GIVING
$150 BILLION TO FIGHT TERROR AND
PROXY WARS.
>> Anthony: HE HAS THE UKRAINE
ISSUE AS WELL.
>> Sean: THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE.
>> Anthony: I TOLD HIS FRIEND
JESSE COME HE'S MALE, PALE AND
STALE.
>> Sean: [LAUGHTER]
>> Anthony: IF YOU HAPPEN TO
BE MALE AND PALE BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT VERY STALE, SEAN.
I THINK THE GUY --
>> Sean: GOOD TO HAVE YOU
BACK.
BUT LOOK, HERE IS THE THING,
ECONOMICS IS YOUR WHEELHOUSE.
NEW GREEN DEAL, OKAY, WE WILL
GET RID OF OIL AND GAS, AND
COMBUSTION ENGINE.
THEN EVERYTHING WILL BE FREE.
EVERYTHING.
WHETHER YOU ARE WILLING OR
UNWILLING TO WORK.
THE CARS, AIRPLANES COME I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE WILL GET --
>> Anthony: FORGET ABOUT THE
COWS BUT THIS IS A FABULOUS
THING.
>> Sean: LIKE A RESTAURANT.
>> Anthony: I HAVE A HUNT AND
FISH CLUB.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE EVERYTHING.
>> Anthony: A LEVEL OF THIS
STUFF BECAUSE IT'S GREAT FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, PEOPLE
LOOK AT THAT, OKAY, MAYBE NOT
GOING TO TELL MY FRIEND IN L.A.
I'M VOTING FOR THEM BUT CLOSE
THE BOOTH.
HE HAS THE ADVERSE EFFECT.
PEOPLE SAY THEY WON'T VOTE FOR
THE PRESIDENT, CLOSE THE COURT
AND VOTE FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: YOU CANNOT HOLD
DONALD TRUMP BACK.
>> Anthony: IF THEY KEEP IT
UP, IT IS A STEP FUNCTION ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OR PERCENTAGE.
>> Sean: QUICK LAST RESPONSE.
>> Anthony: I MISS YOU, SEAN.
>> KEEP SHINING LIGHT ON
HYPOCRISY.
AN APARTMENT WITH A PEN TOWELS,
BERNIE SANDERS LOVES TO FLY
PRIVATE JETS.
SO THEY TALK A GOOD GAME BUT
EVEN TODAY, TOWN HALL, HE IS NOT
INTERESTED IN PAYING THE TAX
RATE THAT HE PROPOSES RIGHT NOW.
SO THEY ARE HYPOCRITES.